[Musique]
je
non
[Musique]
mais tu vois ni qu'elle agirait acheter
adrien dès ce mois ci même un steve wynn
alité minoli kawaii à une promo france
abonde to be mangaka matt groening boîte
hachinohe bâton nos dynamiques ce look
character far far from his home doit
rien faire des interviews mon toubib
mangaka du tout sûrs nervous i'm not
again à papa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
connais tu vois adrien death coco que
lui tout est moulé chi un taulier non
tsiganes massa adrian adrien à mangaka
look what hashino manga death ichi ban
na li masse very good i'm happy to be in
japan à oraison du toubib mangaka new
mendes humide le qca de bateaux and
fight de cash et actions
c'est quoi ça on me dit ça donc c'est
moi ça reste portage ok je me suis
trompé que la fille a failli lcos cannes
ou de dégâts mais mc abonji canada oui
on y fonda qui moquaient collection
achetée à saadouni bata qui n'a acheté
tomorrow un style à cette audience n'est
hockey acheta jean gonna save
on
[Musique]
du coup on a nos locaux
mr
moi
[Musique]
sous le maillot lyonnais mais les locaux
étaient conditionnées à ses côtés oui
celle là celle qui passe par tous les
endroits fréquentés en droit ok merci
[Musique]
mais le sait
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout seul
et bis nom et b su aller gâteau a
allégué temps ok
et
vous
[Musique]
oh
le seul sujet ait au total entre 3 h et
jusqu'à ce qu'ils trouvent ça gâche
telle masse de 4 tonnes d'obus
ok ok sinon nos bureaux neufs
je ne veux pas boire comme un crampon
points jusqu alors
[Applaudissements]
hélas les ailes
m
[Applaudissements]
moi j'avais vu depuis que je suis gamin
mon rêve c'est d'être ici de devenir
mangaka augeard on m'a dit n'y va pas et
j'aurais dû les écouter j'ai perdu mes
dessins je me retrouve avec vous
voilà six mois
[Applaudissements]
je vais y aller
après
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous
oh
[Musique]
on
oh
[Musique]
et pas la réponse
oh
[Musique]
sur la scène sur scène ouais
connais tu vois adrien death i'm looking
for minori ismmee nos rivières do you do
mineur ihsane ça gâche t i mas watashi
no et moi terrasse man running in all i
want you either side est encore minorées
ittihad rien comme your decision
jackings minori string kokan file eux
auront toute équipe bac tu es à y
attacher nos et classels qu'aux
annonceurs
oui non poux saur patassé naufrage de
danton modem intégré testé certains non
non ce sont nos stands à la con qui nous
apprenait qu'une artiste et je signale à
la caunette opté qui la mettait ses
sapins ouattara qu'il a été acquis leur
métal valley utah réseau my wings a
bondi de bach gouvenain ce que j'attende
à terre
boeing est notre hôte
vous avez jeté mais ce sont les mêmes
effets
[Musique]
où
vous avez du papier ou du pépin tant
qu'ami
[Musique]
kylie
non
et sur mesure
jean together team honda martin
bon ok go 2,14 à requérir une phantom
tempo louis de la teuf crise tu essaies
ok ok
[Musique]
moulinsart
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
idiot
merci
mo
[Musique]
spotify ya un bien ok ok les
seconds à 12 minutes du compte cela a
été possible
madame madame annie ailleurs mike
collier tribal milliers d'hommes et
houston dallas en assez bon mais pas au
niveau
ok merci beaucoup a dit gâtés avec des
manches à balai ou tuer ou haydn là
quand tu te dis
[Musique]
cette fois
ap et quand un nom un auteur de manga
maman watashi thaçi le manga comme écho
aux connaisseurs
ces immenses et au collet craint la
géothermie watashi thaçi team tech
she did hockey
[Musique]
ça
nani mom
m
tu vois
tu m'aimes était rien
kiwi
camani
ultime 1 2
cette semaine
[Musique]